why
so as we begin to come to a close
involving the tie-ins of civil war issue
number four we transition to cable and
Deadpool issue number 31 now if you
recall our discussion with cable and
Deadpool issue number 30 we had talked
about how cable and Deadpool had really
kind of I guess maybe had the very early
formations of being opposed to one
another about how Deadpool had chosen
the side of the government he had chosen
the pro Registration side and cable was
really kind of leading leaning towards
anti-registration but at this point
hadn't necessarily made his goals quite
clear in the sense that we didn't know
exactly where he stood with cable and
Deadpool issue number 31 we get a more
clear-cut instance of where cable stands
in terms of superhuman registration in
addition we really kind of pick up with
the end of cable and Deadpool issue
number 30 where we saw the Deadpool had
confronted Captain America and his team
now as you'll notice with the comic book
panel here Goliath is alive and the
whole reason for this is because as we
know this comic takes place
chronologically for the most part before
the events of Goliath death but as we'll
see the comic really kind of covers
three different time spectrums and what
I mean by that is the comic initially
starts out before the death of Goliath
it continues throughout do Goliath's
death and then it ends after the death
of Goliath so it really kind of covers
everything before after or before during
and after the events of Civil War issue
number four and what we see is that
Deadpool is confronting and fighting all
of Captain America's group in addition
to Captain America and for the most part
he's able to handle his own quite well
he's really kind of able to not
necessarily go toe-to-toe physically
with a Hercules but is able to
outmaneuver him the same thing goes for
Goliath and it's really kind of funny
here because in classic Deadpool fashion
you really kind of see him continuing
this element of what he considers to be
an inner monologue when in reality he's
speaking outwardly in addition he's
really kind of I guess maybe narrating
his own actions here and this is really
what kind of makes Deadpool funny in
these comics is they really kind of sets
this
Paige for himself and really kind of has
a series of quick quips and one-liners
as the comic really kind of progresses
and Deadpool continues to fight the the
team of Captain America Captain America
eventually brings a conflict to an end
and he really kind of stops Hercules
from effectively pummeling Deadpool and
he tells Hercules that Deadpool is
really just kind of doing what's
expected of him and they really had
always kind of known but at some point
along the line Deadpool was going to get
involved in the Civil War event which
side he was going to choose they didn't
really know but Captain America really
kind of indicates here that he always
had kind of known that Deadpool would
have chosen the pro Registration side
most likely but we see that Hercules as
patience is really kind of wearing thin
here and that he really doesn't enjoy
the presence of what he considers to be
a gesture like Deadpool and then Captain
America kind of asked the question what
should we do with him from here Kable
appears and Cable says it's fine if
Hercules pummels Deadpool for a little
while because Deadpool has a healing
factor in that eventually he'll recover
from here we see that cable confronts
Deadpool and really kind of acknowledges
the fact that the two of them are on
opposite sides and he actually goes as
far as to try to bribe Deadpool and tell
Deadpool that he'll double whatever it
is that he's being paid to do I guess
try to capture superheroes Deadpool is a
little hesitant here and then cable goes
as far as to say that he'll give him a
bigger badge than the one they already
has and this is where Deadpool again has
one of his funnier moments because he's
really kind of torn here the element or
the idea of having a bigger badge is
almost enough to turn him but not quite
he tries to fire some of his
tranquilizers at cable but because of
Gables gravimetric field the
tranquilizers bounce off of him and they
actually end up hitting Deadpool instead
from here Deadpool falls unconscious and
Captain America asks you know how long
will he be out for and cable replies not
nearly long enough and so they ask what
should we do with him and cable says it
get as much duct tape as you can and use
one roll of duct tape forced mouth and
this is really kind of a funny element
when it really kind of pays homage to
how often Deadpool talks now from here
we should the Deadpool is really just
kind of trying to struggle to get out of
his bombs he's really kind of trying to
trying to get I guess
we execute his escape and the more he
fights the tighter the bonds become the
least likely it is that he's going to be
able to escape in addition he
acknowledges the fact that he has to go
pee and for the next few panels this is
really the only focus that he has so he
just really has to go to the bathroom
that he really has to go pee and this is
probably one of my favorite parts
because it's classic Deadpool this is
this is classic Deadpool right here this
is simply just Deadpool struggling
duct-taped to a chair and he just really
has to go pee I don't really know how
else to say that it's just it's one of
my favorite parts when it comes to the
to the Deadpool comics but we see that
uh that cable arrives and cable tells
him the game has changed that this is
not really kind of a funny thing anymore
this is something that has to be taken a
lot more seriously now and he says that
Goliath has been killed now mm what's
really kind of cool here is that
Deadpool again really kind of
acknowledges some of the events that had
taken place before civil war despite the
fact that Deadpool for the most part in
in the cable and Deadpool comics is
really kind of off on his own doing his
own thing and what we see is that uh of
course Thor tell I'm sorry
cable tells Deadpool that Thor killed
one of our guys killed Goliath and cable
or Deadpool says the Thor was dead and
cable says someone forgot to tell him
that in addition to you know the fact
that that at cable or that Thor was
supposed to be one of the good guys and
someone didn't tell him that either from
here we really kind of see that a cable
cuts Deadpool loose and says that
they're basically going to be going on a
mission they're going to be
transitioning they're going to be going
somewhere else and cable body slides to
both of them to the White House now from
here he's in the Oval Office and he's
trying to converse with the president
tells the president to keep his guards
down to not allow the Secret Service to
shoot at him because if they do the
bullets will bounce off of him due to
his gravimetric field and it may very
well assassinate the president from here
this is one of the most important parts
of the comic and the reason why is
because this gives us a firm
understanding of where cable stands
regarding the Civil War event but it's
also a little bit of humor Deadpool is
still having to pee he still has to use
the bathroom and so he eventually asked
the Pres
then where's the bathroom at and the
president says that it's the third row
down on the right and so of course he
has one of the Secret Service's scored
him there so that nothing Deadpool can't
really do anything fishy from here we
see the cable really is trying to plead
with the president trying to tell the
president that while he is in support of
superhuman Registration he is against
the idea of the fifty state initiative
now if you recall our discussion with
the Civil War frontline and the whole
negative zone and whatnot we had talked
about how the fifty state initiative was
an idea by Reed Richards and iron man
and others to have a
government-sanctioned superhero team in
all 50 states in addition there would be
a portal to the negative zone in all 50
states and cables concern here is that
this will really kind of lead to a
totalitarian state where you will have a
fifty state initiative that will start
with the greatest intentions and then
eventually it'll turn into a police
state and that these superheroes will
not exist to simply govern other
superheroes they won't exist a really
kind of maintain law and order but they
will become oppressive and he goes as
far as to say that cables future or
cables life cables past is this presents
future and cable really kind of comes
with a warning saying that if you
continue down this road
if you continue what you're doing the
results are going to be something that
will evolve into a real civil war
because at this point the Civil War
conflict such as it is is really kind of
a conflict between superheroes it's
really not that major of an event
involving society as a whole for the
most part normal humans haven't
necessarily been impacted in the sense
that they're able to continue going
about their daily lives they're able to
continue their normal operations they
can go to work and they can talk to
their kids and so on and so forth
cable says that if this continues this
will result in a civil war that will
affect everyone it will not simply just
affect your average superhero but the
president doesn't want to hear this and
the reason why is because the president
says he's not too concerned about
something that's going to happen 50
years away that his concern is the
voters in November and this is kind of a
tip of the hat to or I guess maybe kind
of a a criticism of sorts the
politicians in the sense that one of the
biggest criticisms of modern-day
politicians is that they don't care
about the future
they just care about getting reelected
what we see is that the Secret Service
agents began to start shooting a cable
and cables a is able to deflect all of
their bullets in addition we see the
National Guard arrives and the National
Guard begins attacking cable but cable
access is something called the info net
which is basically all the electronic
transmissions that exist on the planet
Earth and he begins downloading the
contents of the Congressional library
into the minds of these soldiers now and
won't necessarily kill them all it will
do is just simply keep their minds
overwhelmed to the point that they are
incapable of doing anything whatsoever
and this is when cable again begins to
really kind of I guess maybe become a
little more harsh with a president where
he says that this is not a joke this is
not some kind of a ruse or anything this
is a serious issue and that what you're
doing here is only going to lead to a
horrible future and that you have to
stop now and he says that that he'll be
present that cable will be there and
that the President himself will be
watching on as an elderly man when his
successor is signing a treaty of
surrender and we would go as far as to
presume that most likely what cable
means is that this civil war that will
take place will most likely kind of be a
civil war between superheroes and
humanity which is really kind of maybe
Days of Future past s kind of concept
and if you guys remember our discussion
about the Days of Future past we had
talked about how the influence of the
Days of Future past would be seen in
virtually every single crossover that
would ever come after the Days of Future
past and this is really kind of a homage
to that this is really kind of an
instance where we kind of see Marvel
pointing the finger in saying that the
Days of Future past timeline it's not
something that can't happen it's not
something that may never happen it's
entirely possible that it might and so
it's really kind of Marvel telling us
that the possibility of a Days of Future
past kind of future is always there just
because the events were thwarted by
Kitty Pryde doesn't mean that it could
never happen from here we see that
Deadpool arrives back after using the
bathroom and the president addresses
Deadpool directly and asked Deadpool if
he is a member of the of the pro
registration group and Deadpool answer
yes and so the president says your job
now is to apprehend cable dead or alive
and this brings an end to cable and
Deadpool issue number 31